the strongest criticism heard inside
Cuba since the death of Fidel Castro
isn't from dissidents it's from young
left wingers who say the revolution has
stagnated and is under threat Josue
veloster alve is a researcher at the
Havana branch of the Latin American
Institute for Social Sciences he warns
that different groups may try and hijack
the legacy of Fidel Castro for their own
purposes significant of years old
there's going to be a battle to define
what feeder was about they'll find an
aspect of Fidel that can be used by the
government while at the same time Cuba
silently returns to capitalism or
they'll build a new kind of capitalism
will also be waiting for the forces of
reaction from abroad or inside the
country to seize his legacy oh really I
guess I o'farrell Iraq Co handling then
oo laga top well following Donald
Trump's election victory in the United
States many Cubans believe that Castro's
brand of anti-imperialism will remain
alive and many believe that if
Washington reham poses sanctions Cubans
will react with an entrenched
nationalism above all from young people
who see Trump as an affront
what Trump says is irrelevant it lacks
respect above all because an entire
nation is suffering Trump represents a
minority in the United States the
majority of people did not vote for him
we need to prepare for what's coming we
shouldn't lose faith but get ready for
what can happen the Cuban government is
counting on the country's youth to
continue its model although thousands
emigrate to escape the economic crisis
in Cuba there's a sense that the death
of Fidel Castro has led to a resurgence
of willingness to save the socialist
legacy he created whatever our link in
ass it's probable that no one will be
able to do anything in Cuba without
Fidel being mixed up in what they're
doing that goes for the reactionary
forces or the government Cabrera door
sociali tell our tourism and it's the
same for those who want to deepen many
aspects of the socialist revolutionary
project in Cuba instead of rolling it
back once emotions have calmed down it
will become clearer which legacy of
Fidel Castro young people will choose